this episode of the honeydew is brought
to you by liquid iv
ritual trough and go henry more on that
later
let's get into the do the honeydew with
ryan zickler
welcome back to the honeydew y'all we
are over here doing it
in the night pants studios i'm ryan
sickler ryan stickler.com ryan sickler
on all your social media um i want to
just let you know now it's a little
early but we're doing it anyway i'm
starting to promote dates so
let me look at them september 16th
through the 18th i will be in
phoenix phoenix house of comedy
september 16th through the 18th go to my
website ryan sickler.com tickets will be
available there
and please subscribe to the youtube
channel don't just watch hit that
subscribe it means
nothing to you and everything to us
everything
hit the subscribe and thank you for your
support the community continues to grow
and grow
um and the patreon as well the honeydew
with you all if you
or someone you know you do not have to
be a member of the patreon
has that story that has to be heard
submit it to honeydewpodcast
gmail.com nowhere else even though you
guys keep sending it everywhere else and
then yelling at me because i don't
respond
to your email that's not sent where i
said to send it
and then i don't respond to being yelled
at okay so honeydewpodcastgmail.com
that's where you send your stories and
hopefully we have to do an episode with
y'all
all right it's a lot of fun i loved my
[ __ ] job
and the stories are we just had a guy
get a kidney transplant
from his best friend who kind of didn't
want to [ __ ] do it
uh so check it out all right it's only
five bucks a month and you now
get um the honeydew audio and video on
mondays a day early ad free at no
additional cost
there's no cost to it all right it's
five bucks a month sign up for a year
it's a month free all right you guys
know i record here at the santa monica
music
center uh working through with outreach
through the arts right now creating a
couple podcasts i'm also teaching a high
school class at culver city now
uh teaching them how to podcast ash and
i are having fun with these kids
and uh teaching them a lot of stuff so
you'll be seeing stuff coming out
eventually when uh you know it's gotta
be all approved through school and [ __ ]
so
um anyway you guys know what we do here
all right we highlight the low lights
uh it's a beautiful [ __ ] show y'all and
um
today the stories behind this
storyteller i'm sure
are gonna be some [ __ ] we've never heard
guys
uh back again here ladies and gentlemen
please welcome
jason ellis y'all welcome back to the
honey finally
[ __ ] big dude this is a big day for
me i had no idea how big it was
to be here the first time it's like
uh you are my you should change the name
to the ryan sickler experience because
it's heavy for me everybody joe rogan
might have a problem with that
okay we should probably not [ __ ] with
him but i should we should
i want i like you you should be my
representation to
all the public of podcasting because i
feel like
you just i everybody accepts me
through ryan sickler this is the it is
dude this is
i don't talk enough you should come on
my show and anytime you want me here i
should come on here
and that's it for me i don't need to
book anybody i don't need to talk to
anybody
hey man we got oprah why why i got
sickler
everybody loves sickler i don't
understand why i would get overwhelmed
someone's gonna be like oh yeah no
that's what [ __ ] kisses some chicks
love it dude you guys are hilarious like
that's very flattering it makes me feel
[ __ ] good man
podcast survey since i've seen you
that's what i know that's what i've got
well i'm glad to have you back
any time you [ __ ] want i mean your
[ __ ] last time was just
it's it's absolutely one of the most
commented
um on show and i told you guests come on
and they sit down over like i don't know
man i don't know i don't have any jason
ellis stories i'm like yeah only jason
ellis has jason ella's stories
yeah so real quick before we get into
everything please plug
everything right now we'll do it again
at the end but please get that out now
yeah so the jason ellis show that would
be
it's that's my show putting a lot of
work into that so if anybody would like
to check that out
comes out every tuesday at midnight the
jason ellis show podcast it's free yeah
it's on youtube
all that stuff like and subscribe that
would be really cool all right and then
hawk vs wolf
first episode drops on the 24th of may
and that's a podcast with tony hawk and
me
talking about um life obviously based
from
uh older skateboarders all right i can't
wait to [ __ ] listen to that
i really like it because he's way better
of a storyteller now
and he's past the talking only for 11
year olds and under
like he can just say a story that's like
that involves being a mature adult
and it's like whoa because he never
usually
exposes that also he gets vulnerable on
there huh
yeah i love that well it's also that's
what i say all the time like
you to see the maturity of that man like
that's the michael jordan of [ __ ]
skating
right yeah tony hawk he's the he's the
pinnacle of [ __ ] skateboarding we all
love tony hawk
but to what to him to talk with you
about his
challenges his fuck-ups his immature
[ __ ] like
i would love to hear that like damn tony
hawk did that [ __ ] you know that's i
think it's
i think it's very uplifting actually
yeah no he's surprisingly
he he went through a lot of struggles
and as a fan from when i didn't know him
as a youngster
knowing that there were certain times
where he was struggling
for the way he was being treated in
skateboarding and i was a part of it
you know cause i was like he is a nerd
he has a got a pink helmet on
and he doesn't do you know what
christian or soy did so there was like
two sides and to know that
he wished he was cooler or sometimes he
regrets that he didn't party
and i'm like man i'm glad you didn't
you know because people needed the other
side to because he's a better influencer
than anybody else if you looked up
to him in skateboarding that was a that
was a good idea
he was doing the right thing yeah he's
still doing you just brought up michael
jordan
imagine if michael jordan still played
basketball i know and still 360 duncan
tony play basketball but [ __ ] played
tony is at the ramp
yes i watch him i love him i love what
he does me and me too
so that's weekly what tell me yeah yeah
everywhere you get podcasts yep hawk and
wolf hawk versus
talk versus what
i'm trying to get him to fight me or
somebody else because he agreed that i
could teach him how to box a little bit
and i was like if i teach you a good one
too
then you got to like fight somebody he's
like who could i fight am i
stevo you can fight stevo but
he probably won't do it but i'm just
trying to get tony to punch people
i think it's funny he's not a fighter
yeah he doesn't look like a fighter
no but i was still on the same punch i
want to see you punch me too i'll punch
you if you let me punch you i'll punch
you
i appreciate that yeah no problem yeah
i'm the same way i need a little bit of
the pain i get it
yeah yeah and i just feel like it would
be fun you know let's get a good workout
you can really go for it you know
i will just go for it i'll be throwing
up missing you
it's only three minutes but it gets it
does get 300 minutes when you haven't
[ __ ] boxed yeah you're probably good
for
i've trained i've never boxed i've i've
worked on bags but do you jog or
anything
no hell no do i look like i do road work
i don't know dude
christian [ __ ] runs every day and
he's way fatter than you
come on he's almost a super athlete
for like good shape i [ __ ] can't
believe it he said he always says that
mickey mantle gene he must really have
that
now the machine is a good name for him
yeah yeah all right so uh let's talk man
the last episode was just
mind-blowing [ __ ] yeah you know there's
been nothing
uh like that um but there was
obviously we didn't get that all your
stuff so you've struggled with heroin
you've struggled with addiction
obviously um tell me about
all right what's the let me ask you this
way what's the what's the best drug
you've ever done what's the most fun
you've ever had doing a drug um
i mean i think that's got to be uh
excluding weed we're not even
going to be molly right is that right
i've never feel like i mean to me
the best time is when you're having sex
if i could do
like a skateboard trick and have sex at
the same time that'd be pretty good
but it's just pretty difficult you know
to do that like one time i had sex with
a girl photo
shopping charlie but but we were going
down the road in a grocery cart
yeah yeah because we found it on the
side of the road and i was like it'd be
cool if we did that
dude i'm the same way i'll tell i'll
share go ahead but it
going down the road the road was like a
little bit like that so it started to go
off towards the
gutter i'm not going to pump her into
the gutter and go
ask first with my dick stuck in somebody
somebody could get
really hurt like i don't even know what
kind of a [ __ ] what kind of slam that
in
like my head on the ground and a boner
in somebody like you can snap your boner
too
you could probably [ __ ] really hard like
that dog but
crack your [ __ ] head and make it nut
everywhere i'm not a s
for you i never thought i was going to
say this but i'm not a [ __ ] slammer
[Laughter]
did not know that i was going to say
that today thank you you're welcome yeah
yeah but heroin is wait let's go back
okay there's some weird places you've
had sex so i okay
we drove past the construction site uh
like you know how they leave the
bulldozers overnight because nobody has
to steal the face
wait in the seat no on the [ __ ]
on on the treads we just stood up on it
on the oh on the
on the yeah well the cat the the you
know the doors are locked and they take
the keys
so we just stood up on the tread because
that you know the treads like just
doggies
yeah standing up doggy style yeah um but
the one i'm the one that got away
this one bummed me out we tried but it
was protected um there happened to be i
don't know what it was a parade or
whatever but there was a
[ __ ] tank in the parking lot of the
shopping mall
and they had security like one guy but
he would drive the whole [ __ ] mall
so we were trying to get on that tank i
wish i could say i had sex on a tank but
i we couldn't we tried we were sneaking
up
trying to get that guy come by with a
flashlight [ __ ] like god damn man yours
are way more glorious than
gloria why would your shopping cart what
else do you have i i had sex with a
chick in a in a dog kennel
and she was she i follow her now on
instagram she has like a kid and stuff
she's a nice like she's like a nice lady
but at the time i was living with some
pro surfers
and i had this weird little room where i
was uh
smoking coke a lot and i didn't know how
to do
crack and my nose would hurt from doing
so much coke so i would just sprinkle
coke
you're snorting it and okay so you
switched to smoking it because you're
yeah is that like a cocoa puffy in a way
yeah that's what we called it yeah right
so
cocoa puffs so i had these i bought i
mean pro skateboarder no real
other life i bought guinea pigs or
gerbils or something i don't know what
they were little guys
and uh they all [ __ ] and
made like i go on to a contest and come
back and they'd be like
there was like a hundred of them are you
dude they eat each other's heads and
nuts
i saw heads and i'm like you ate
somebody ate somebody's come back and it
would be dead and it'd be missing an ass
there was heads
like somebody that did i swear
gerbils have no remorse like they do not
play
they [ __ ] eat and they're babies i
don't know any of this
again apparently i can only i can only
tell you from like
outside looking in i'm not in the
community but when i
but you're not the joker i'm not in the
german community [ __ ] proud to say
that actually
a lot of people probably were worried
about that is he
a member of the gerbil community or is
he not because i know he's a raging homo
so you never know
turns out i'm not never put animals in
me so yeah they
but uh and then i had a it was like a
really crusty
smelly box of slaughter
and then so she didn't really want to
[ __ ] in there and i was like we just
[ __ ] the dog kennel
she's got really nice teeth she was a
dental dental assistant
i'm not gonna say what i called her
because i don't think it's she had a
name for herself
because she was and yeah no you're doing
well i didn't do it
yeah but yeah dog kennel so never really
anything
uh you know on the top of a mountain or
you know i mean on a ship or
you know i never we used to just drive
around there would be a cornfield we'd
be like you want to go [ __ ] in the
cornfield
yeah just pull over and run off into the
cornfield you can't see you [ __ ]
there and come back
once i howled in a girl's ass
on the roof of her house
i was so proud of myself it was super
hard to get her up there too she was so
useless
was it harder to get her up there or
harder to howl in her ass it's not that
hard
[Laughter]
especially when you got a nice ass in
front of it you know
you get right into it
i still think that's such a glorious
thing to do
oh i was in like the i just see you i
just see the silhouette in a full moon
that's what i thought yeah that's what i
visualized i was like that's
living you know and is it was it a flat
roof or was it like this
like oh there was like the shingles yeah
yeah the dangerous man
come on [ __ ]
for her no you don't give
i would sincerely i would [ __ ] jump
in front of her face and push her back
i'm not that guy sure i know you're
you're a gentleman yeah
i am sure everyone wants to know uh what
technically you mean by howling like did
you literally [ __ ] oh
oh oh oh oh [ __ ]
yeah i was just really drunk and i would
like saying it you know i like saying
i'm gonna hail in your ass
and then she was like i'll do it and i
was like okay let's do it
no one ever did it i never did it again
god
and it wasn't like a weird kinky thing
it was just it was a one-and-done yeah
just i always liked wolves you know i
like james hadfield because he would
have on his guitar he had the fretboard
where yeah
it was a man that turned into a wolf
like not a man
monkey turned into a man you don't even
get it i'm the wolf man you [ __ ]
idiots i'm like i like that
yeah he's cool i love that dude yeah
right that was my first concert ever
metallica and ozzy osbourne i was in
seventh grade we convinced our parents
to let us go and i will never forget
seeing cliff burton
oh wow you saw clifford's birthday i did
i saw cliff we were in seventh grad stop
the ticket stub saw cliff burton
so it was ozzy osbourne ultimate sin he
was the headliner metallica was the
opening band fest or whatever no this
was way before that this is like
i'm in seventh it's the 80s yeah so
it's just on regular tour ozzie's the
headliner
metallica's opening and it's the master
puppets album
yeah right yeah and they come out and we
have been listening to master puppets
like we had
they got so it was me my brother and my
buddy jason
and um dan olaski and um
his older brother brian was like you all
need to check this ride the lightning
[ __ ] out really yeah
the [ __ ] is this you know and then we
were like whoa
so we got in early on then went back you
know we're listening to kill em all and
everything and then master of puppets
hits
our minds are blown like these guys are
the fastest hardest rocking band
we've ever heard and then we go to the
concert it's three we're in seventh
grade
we convinced our parents to let us go
together we sat in the last row under
the pavilion
people are passing joints down and we're
so scared you know we're just passing
them right along like you probably would
like
how old are you in seventh grade cause i
don't think i went to school maybe oh no
i went to school that long
um and then did we talk about that you
dropped out of school
um hold on we're coming back but i
remember
and it's so funny because i crank
metallica for my daughter all the time
she loves them
and she's like dad do you think their
heads hurt when they bang i go you know
what's so funny and i told
this story this is why we're in a
simulation i just told this story to her
like two days ago that yeah i
[ __ ] couldn't believe seeing cliff
burton like he didn't half-ass it this
motherfucker's head
was banging the entire [ __ ] time
and cr i mean not just little dude
cranking
and i remember being a kid just
mesmerized by this guy and then it was
not even i don't even think it was a
month later they had the bus accident
and he died so i got to see him and then
i got
then years later i went to monsters of
rock and it was
that was a good was faith no more and
then metallica had the middle set
and then it was gnr but i always thought
metallica had
the better set because they had that day
into sunset
in tonight you know what i mean i
thought that was sick so you got a
little bit of daylight and they're
playing for their hour and a half two
hours
and by the time they're done it's black
now you know what i mean
um and then of course gnr comes out an
hour later because they don't want to go
[ __ ] follow that [ __ ] let's take a
quick break and tell you about our first
sponsor liquid iv now when we push our
body hard or we're just feeling run down
it's extremely important to take care of
ourselves
with the proper vitamins and nutrients
that's why liquid iv
created hydration multiplier plus immune
support to maintain and strengthen
your immune system look i've been
talking about it for months you guys
know
all through covet i took liquid iv uh
everyone i know
takes it i give it to every comic that
comes in here that wants it
uh my neighbors take it everybody's
taking it right now they love it it's
good for
just staying hydrated people taking it
after their nights out drinking now the
place is open back up
uh it's good stuff man and the whole
time i really
i like the uh tangerine that has the
zinc
and the antioxidants and everything in
there which is what i want to tell you
about so the hydration multiplier plus
immune support is a cutting edge blend
of vitamin c zinc and well immune in
convenient single serving packets
to help strengthen your immune system
each packet is bursting with
fresh natural tangerine flavor it tastes
so good i promise you liquid iv can
provide two to three times
faster and more efficient hydration than
water alone when you purchase liquid iv
you're joining their mission to help
people live better lives everywhere
all right so get your liquid ivs
hydration multiplier plus immune support
and bulk at costco or
order online and get 25 off when you go
to liquidive.com
and use the code honeydew at checkout
that's 25 off of anything you order when
you get better hydration today using
promo code honeydew
at liquidive.com our next sponsor is
ritual we deserve to know what we're
putting in our bodies and why especially
when it comes to something that we take
every day rituals clean vegan friendly
multivitamin is formulated with high
quality nutrients in bioavailable forms
your body can actually use what you
won't find
are sugars gmos major allergens
synthetic fillers and artificial
colorants all right
i've been talking about it for months as
well ritual i've been looking for a
daily vitamin i used to take the old
standard stuff
then i really started reading what was
in them and i was like look man i'm
getting older i don't have time for
dust like i need some real vitamins in
this stuff and then ritual comes around
i love taking it look i still can't
smell
and i can kind of taste and it's got a
minty little fresh flavor that i can
actually taste
in this vitamin all right uh i've been
taking
it now for probably six or eight months
uh and a multivitamin should contain key
nutrients and forms your body can
actually use to help fill gaps in the
diet there's no shady extras
ritual is made traceable all right
you'll always know what nutrients you're
taking and where they come from
thanks to rituals one of a kind visible
supply chain ritual makes healthy habits
easy your multivitamins are delivered to
your door every month with free shipping
always
you can start snooze or cancel your
subscription anytime
and if you don't love ritual within your
first month
they'll refund your first order all
right get key nutrients without the bs
ritual is offering my listeners 10 off
during your first three months
visit ritual.com honeydew to start your
ritual today
now let's get back to the duke yeah he
was a [ __ ] though
axel was always [ __ ] and if you're
trying to compete and you're a guy that
parties and metallica was more of like
yeah they party but they were also
way more interested in being the best so
at that time you were probably
going to lose if there was some sort of
and you know he's like a hunter and [ __ ]
and basically you had to get out of san
francisco
and [ __ ] like that he's he's like sober
now he had like tons of battles with it
too yeah
he's a beast i love all of them i love
the but you know what i love and that's
why i love
our fans like the support that whole
thing where if you've ever seen their
behind the music where there was
some band coming on before them when
they were coming up in san francisco but
they were already super popular
underground up there
and they said the whole audience turned
their backs and just went like this
until that band got off the stage
because they were like we're not here to
see you
all right i mean they were that good
dude that's a
i mean errors of music and then go back
and listen to that master of puppets is
it's a masterpiece it absolutely is and
then to hear them
do it with the symphony and everything
else it's great they're waiting speaking
of masterpieces back to your drunk
stories
which one what happened what's this one
about you're saying something about in a
tent
oh man okay so i'm sponsored by pao
parelto
it's uh it's i was on pal because
uh the the bones brigade had existed
before me
and steve caballero who was in the bones
brigade was still
on pal at the time so i was like holy
[ __ ] i could be on a team with steve
caballero
yes i will i'll do the deal so i'm on
the team i got to ask you sorry to
interrupt
what which one gotten which one went to
prison was it hasoy
okay all right sorry go ahead so uh i
get on the team and we do some tours and
stuff and i get to meet
stevie and kind of be his friend um but
obviously
stevie is steve caballero so it's not
i've never been
my party side never really flexes in
front of steve kevin steve
stevie because he's he's on the bonus
brigade and he could call
george powell and i just don't want to
look bad in front of somebody who
is such a legend so i always try to kind
of
you know do the demo and i'm like yeah
steven alright man and then
i'm gonna take off and then and then i
go get crazy so we're on this tour
i think it's big day out so there's all
rock and roll bands and all this [ __ ]
and every tour every every place we get
we just get a tent
so everyone gets a tent and it's you
know it's australia summertime
so i go out that night and i get [ __ ]
super ham and i used to do this thing
when i was super hammond
where i would say quick and wherever i
was i'm standing there i'm you can hang
out i'm standing there and then i go
quick impression mel meninga mel meninga
is like this [ __ ]
uh uh like native new zealand guy that
played in rugby
i don't even follow rugby i just
remember this moment in your duty would
always just knock
everybody over and then i'd run off and
just smash something
okay so i'm partying on i mean some city
in australia how old are you at this
time
25 26 okay and i go quick impression
malmo [ __ ]
you know run off and there's a trash can
that's like bolted to a
a pole on the sidewalk and i [ __ ] you
know i mean jump and smash into it and
it
snaps and spins around it hits the car
on the
like parked next to it and then the
bouncer comes out and he's going to beat
me up and
and everybody comes out and goes no he
didn't mean it and then they go well you
better get the [ __ ] out of here and i'm
like [ __ ] sorry whatever
go back to the tent and uh i go to take
a piss before i get in the tent and i'm
talking to myself drunk as a as an
[ __ ]
and i just fell back and i've never
usually when you fall like if you ever
like get frightened when you're paying
you can kind of stop
but because i was so wasted i was trying
to get my dick
to like steer it somewhere because i try
to get up and i'm like wow i can't get
up
and i'm like instead of fear yeah
because it's doing the
[ __ ] [ __ ] wheels
and i'm like where is it and i mean i'm
like stop doing it at me
and then finally i mean i'm like oh my
by the time i [ __ ] get my dick in my
hand
it's i've pissed all over myself and i'm
like god damn it
i get in the tent i'm like man what kind
of idiot
does that and then i go to sleep and i
wake up and it's
[ __ ] i mean obviously i went to bed
late and now it's in a
stinking hot summer sun and i've been
asleep
sit you know i mean it's probably about
11 i would say so i've been baking in
there
so i wake up
i wake up and my face is wet and i see
my hand
and my phone next to my hand and it's
under water
because the tent is a plastic base and
i'm like
what the [ __ ] why is it underwater
and i like lift my head up and i'm like
i [ __ ] pissed myself how many times
what i dude i filled i like maybe it was
just like more weight in the head area
but the main area of the piss puddle
was it was your phones dude and it was
like it wasn't like the phones of today
it was like a chunky one and that
[ __ ] thing was
it was gone it was submerged and this is
back when phones that go
submerge they don't come back dude you
don't like try the sim card out or some
[ __ ] it's over
oh god so i see that and i'm like oh my
god
and i'm like my face is super puffy and
i'm uh
i [ __ ] um like try to unzip the tan
and put my head out there
and i put my head out there and i'm like
oh the the
like uh i just sort of moved it out of
the way i put my head out there and
steve caballero is coming
from the showers with like you know
his [ __ ] bathroom kit [ __ ] towel
because he's all organized
and my face is all swollen and [ __ ] and
i didn't even know this but apparently
he was returning from the shower
he'd already walked by and apparently my
leg was hanging out the whole time
so apparently i didn't even make it all
the way into the tent when i made a piss
puddle for myself
and there was a line of ants going
across the back of my leg
just rolling right along so steve
caballero is telling the story in the
bus
and i'm like i'm i'm fired like i'm
kicked off for sure
and then he just thought it was funny or
whatever
i remember thinking this is not what i
want to show steve caballero yeah i was
pretty bummed out about that
but that's that's a fun one right
yeah yeah i mean it didn't hurt you
right now heroin was always this who
it's
it's how do you
what are you doing that you finally
transitioned to heroin
but you also it could just be somebody's
like hey let's try this i don't know
well that the first time i ever did it
was black tar heroine in vancouver what
exactly is black
tell me about it that's what i said i
just want to know about it
i know i did i've had two experience one
time i snorted but i'm gonna get into
that one i've
uh the first time i did it pro
skateboarder and i would be
doing all these bumps and then he's like
we should get some heroin i was like
yeah what's that like
he's like oh if you get some black tar
heroin you can just smoke it it's mellow
and i was like
oh okay sure we'll let's go to man
what's the [ __ ] park in vancouver
that's
sketchy as hell some parkway head or
something
where somebody i forgot what it's called
but we're there you know
three in the morning anyone got any
heroin like it's not very but somebody
gave us some
and then i remember you know he showed
me you put this is your first time and
you weren't you were
like yup all the way you weren't like i
don't know well this guy sounded like
he'd done it before and he still
skateboarded good
so i figured it's not that bad okay
otherwise i mean he'd be
in trouble so they put the it's it is
it's
it's it looks like vegemite it's like
tar each black [ __ ] and you put it on
the foil i don't know how
any other way you do it put it on the
foil and then you you hold the phone and
then you heat it up and you
smoke it with the pen little glass pipe
pen not just a pen i mean
you could probably do it if you had a
bigger budget but that's not what we
were doing
you hollered out one of those old bics
like the best those are the best
spitball pens you know those white ones
that either had the blue or the black
yeah
we used to hit each other all the time
yeah i remember getting hit by those
so you're [ __ ] this is your first
time
heating it up in the kitchen and then uh
you know hey
i feel it and i'm like cool not the
biggest highlight of my life
but i was like all right black tie
heroine every now and then
seems okay did you feel when you at your
highest did you feel like you could
function you did you feel like you can
go skate on that right then
no [ __ ] way no no there was a beer on
the floor in front of me and i was going
like this in front of it
i was trying to get the beer to go in my
mouth and that's the only part of my
body i could move
and i was like maybe my lip will tip it
and how long did you feel like that
probably an hour or something okay
and then what then didn't you get
addicted or well then i go
then dude this is so weird but to tell
the real truth of it is
in skateboarding i've hooked up with a
trans chick
in australia in front of these two other
pro skateboarders from australia
we left the bar in front of them we were
at a
dinner big dinner party i took a bunch
of ecstasy
and this [ __ ] trans chick comes in
she's [ __ ] hot as [ __ ]
but it's back in the 90s so it's like
nobody
can touch her and i've got a girlfriend
at the time where we were trying to
like have open relationship [ __ ] and
and she knew that i was a little fruity
and i i think she was just mad i don't
know how it really worked but
we locked eyes and we were just into
each other
and we just left together in front of
everybody the girl
yeah i told my girlfriend i'm like i'm
gonna hook up with her and she's like
yeah yeah [ __ ] off
for real yeah so i just leave and i
remember those two going
oh you're [ __ ] gay like you're just
i'm telling and i remember thinking
i just remember thinking
i'm not thinking you're just so hot and
i'm so high
and and this would be the greatest thing
i could ever think of
i'm going so then uh where was i
what was that for just walking out with
a trench yes i walked out with her so
then
later on in life in skateboarding when
those dudes came to america
they decided to not be my friend anymore
because at the time they were my friends
oh so they saw you walk out and that was
the end of your relationship with them
no
no we were friends after that oh you
were but then when he
switched on me in america he decided to
not like me anymore
when he became really good he started
telling everybody
about this encounter that i'd had which
then
it was just you're a an f-bomb that's
ellis is a [ __ ] he hooked up with a with
a [ __ ] that's
at the time that's what they were saying
so i deny it
obviously and everybody else is like i
know right like as if alice would
because alice's go i got all the girls
every like i got the accent
i mean maybe i'm not the best
skateboarder but i got the [ __ ] i can
talk
and i in a minute and i'm a wild guy so
if it's a it's a contest
i'm get i'm getting whoever is like the
local hot chick
i'm get the [ __ ] out of the way like all
the other dudes that are better than me
you don't have the extra game that i
have so no one
ever thought that if you have a lot of
game with girls that you would ever
go the other way so it was almost like
uh you know all this [ __ ] is all
[ __ ]
then tattoo [ __ ] crazy guy i'm just
like trying to hide from the fact that
i'll suck a dick
it's like how tough you mean like
tough guys don't you mean penis [ __ ]
not to kick your ass
it's like tall facade man i'm terrified
and ready to blow
let me okay so let me go back to this
for a second in the
professional skate community um
were there other guys that were gay or
by
the first person good question first
person ever come out brian anderson
okay and brian anderson was a really
famous
really good street skater who was on a
really popular
skateboard company girl skateboards and
everybody just accepted it
and i was like oh wait
you can you can not i know what this is
this is
he's really famous and really popular in
skateboarding and i'm invert
skateboarding the jock
part of skateboarding that's in
carlsbad so is that uh is that like
in the comedy world is he in the alt
scene like he's doing this
yeah okay they're just more open-minded
yeah and i also believe if you're
super popular
it's not it's not i mean if you're just
in the middle
you can i i really feel like it's maybe
the town that i was in
because it was very like a lot of people
said when they'd heard it
hey man i mean i heard you're a [ __ ] but
obviously i know you're not a [ __ ] but if
you were a [ __ ] we wouldn't be cool you
know that and i would tell you that we
wouldn't be
cool my one of my dearest friends one of
the
one of the greatest skateboarders i'm
not going to say his name because he's
still cut up about it i'm trying to get
him
on my show to confess it all because
people have accused him for being a bit
of a homophobe and he was back in the
day
but i think he's an older man now that
kind of regrets it
but well that's good though that means
he grew i told him that story he's like
i don't believe i don't remember that
i'm like it's funny how
nothing to you and it scarred me [ __ ]
forever i remember thinking
we're never real friends ever again
and you don't even know that we're not
real friends ever again
you know that's the that's the thing you
don't realize about
all those little actions that people do
day to day that cut those kind of people
up
terrifies them gets them to do heroin
with prostitutes
yeah tell me about heroin with
prostitutes so the heroine
dies then these guys are talking about
me being gay
in in america and people are questioning
it and i'm
and he's trying to fight me and you're
in the closet you're hiding at the [ __ ]
dude [ __ ] you like i yeah i'm not
telling anybody
um the only person i told was a guy that
uh who's
him sucked yeah so yeah who else do you
got
this the guy that i used to we just [ __ ]
each other and his
wife nah really it started with it
started with a wife i'll do this i'm not
going to say name so it doesn't matter
but
at first it was like at first it was
like do you want to [ __ ] my wife and i
was like yeah
and then it was like uh in the circle do
you run in that you get
asked that more than once i've been
asked once when i had hair i was pretty
attractive
okay i know it's all [ __ ] up now but
it used to be
i used to be strikingly handsome like i
feel like i would be
and then the accent in america maybe
it's died off a little bit now and i've
lost my accent but it used to be blatant
you know i used to be hot i remember it
because i know i'm not now i don't walk
in a room and chicks go oh [ __ ]
they go oh my god what the [ __ ] happened
which is cool everybody has their run
[ __ ] man everybody
got their run you know the other part
though like if there's like full there's
there's certain kinds of chicks that
still think i'm hot and
nine times out of ten those girls
[ __ ] like
real proper so i don't even have i don't
get mismatches
anymore if you're into me that's what's
going to work it's going to work out
right yeah i usually like
you know you know what you like at this
point not you them
yeah i don't i thought we find each
other mm-hmm it's like from across the
room you could hey i'm tweaked
me too you wanna [ __ ] my wife okay
yeah so that one worked into a couple
years down the road doing some e-bombers
and it was like let me just jerk you off
and i was like
i mean like i've already had like three
other
so what you first [ __ ] his wife by
yourself not a female not with him oh
well three oh
okay yeah and he wasn't watching no he'd
be in on the action
and then and then every and then like
sometimes you know getting a little like
sometimes he pull it out and put it and
i'm like whoa
[ __ ] steering my dick like
dang you know what i mean like that was
a power steering
power move i was like power steering
right
and then i
i don't even know if that was that
necessary but he's placing your dick
in his wife yeah and then anyway and
then
film it a lot and he was like so this is
out there of you
for him sure yeah do you think he still
watches it and jerks off of that [ __ ] i
don't want to answer that if he ever
he probably maybe oh yeah
probably not probably but anyway
[Music]
where's my vhsc cassette
[Laughter]
i know that's why i feel like i'm so
safe from talking about it all the time
like
you can't blackmail me hey man i got a
video
you [ __ ] me i'm like go ahead post it
i don't care yeah
yeah it might be a worse look for him
than me but anyway
where did that go from so then yeah that
ends up being where
we both agree that we're bi in the
middle of
doing that and obviously his wife
already knew so it was no big thing so
then after that it was kind of
then you just shifted just you and him
no no i mean there was a couple times
where in the end it was
me and him and he ended up getting
divorced and stuff so he
him and i have had a long line of
everybody we date
we've both had sex with at one point he
had sex with one of my
the wife that used to punch me in the
face sh he
[ __ ] her behind my back yeah while you
were married
yeah and then when we got divorced
because he used to say he's like you
should try and ask her if
if she wants a threesome and i was like
dude trust me she is not the chick
that's going to do with she's not going
to [ __ ] you
and he'd already [ __ ] her so he tells
me
like five years later after i get
divorced he's like yeah man
i mean it was crazy but i did [ __ ] your
wife and i was like
what really and he's like yeah i know
he's
and he was like you know what let me
make it up to you let me give you some
money
and i was like you know i didn't have
any money i was like really like what
kind of money
and i think he gave me like 10 grand or
so holy [ __ ]
yeah just like [ __ ] [ __ ] brought
her a game man
she was really hot 10 000 for one [ __ ]
oh he probably [ __ ] her a couple of
times if i know him
all right 5000 still a lot too bro ain't
more power to them i really don't feel
better to you you got ten thousand
dollars
i made the wolf knives with it like i
made a skateboard company that's still
the wolf
hold on oh [ __ ] you funded a company
with the money you got from a guy who
[ __ ] your wife behind your back
so that's marlo this [ __ ] that's called
doubling down and investing it just
flip it upside down baby
yeah get on down there and grab yourself
a t-shirt
oh my god dude
all right you were heading toward
the hair okay so yeah so
the gay bashing got cr like i got i got
i couldn't do it dude i couldn't go to
contests anymore
it was just because they were bashing
you or just the the the culture itself
was
just not intimidating there'd be like
there was a group of people that were
like 100
sure that he was right so i lost friends
i see so then i had this awkward thing
that was probably a bigger deal to me
than everybody else but i was at the
ramp thinking maybe 20
percent of the people here are not cool
with me anymore because they think i had
sex with a trans person
and and i was like man i can't live like
this and he was always
barking at me at every contest i'm like
you guys just no one would say anything
it's [ __ ] what's up can't [ __ ] suck
and i'm like [ __ ] off dude it's like you
want to [ __ ] go and i'm like no i
don't
want to go i'm terrified of fighting
that was and he knew it you know that's
the then when you know i left
that's another reason why i got into
fighting because i was like that's not
gonna happen to me anymore like you're
not gonna
if you want to go we'll [ __ ] go
because i i've been
i'm i was done with that i was so that's
really that's what drove you into
fighting a lot of it i mean also my
childhood i mean i always wanted to be
able to protect myself
and i just thought i could until i faced
really tough psychopathic people
and i was like you're crazier than me
and i'm [ __ ] scared of that
that's a shock when you meet someone
you're like oh no you're [ __ ] right
you're crazy
so then i had to like rise to it because
if you're crazy you're not
gonna get me anymore like i'll which is
a sh which is terrible because now all i
do is work on not being that person
like you cut me off you say some [ __ ]
like i'm just there i'm ready
like in three seconds i can be like we
can [ __ ] sort it out right now [ __ ]
if you want to go and i'm like
dude stop being that pert like whoever
that person is
cut him out he's not good ever even when
you win
because i'm still a nice person so when
i do that guy
and then i do beat you up i know i'm a
piece of [ __ ]
more than anybody so i'm just i just
don't want to ever
get in that ever again i just walk away
i
that's smart i mean because you could
kill somebody you could everybody could
kill somebody yeah
luckily but you could [ __ ] strike
somebody you there's a strategy yeah you
could throat punch somebody
quick i'll never forget once i'm gonna
tell you this just made me laugh there's
two things
i love how this is funny this is uh so
we're at a house party back in the day
when i played uh
community college um all juco we went to
a house party
and a bunch of the cool guys on the team
would you know about eight to ten of us
would roll deep and we go to these
parties and [ __ ] and we're at this one
guy
he's on the team so everybody's learning
everyone's neighborhood you know i mean
come on we're going to do a party in
our our our neighborhood tonight because
community college you commute you know
yeah
so uh we're at this one guys his peoples
you know his friends from high school
whatever because
we're just out of high school and um
there's this guy drunk and he's talking
[ __ ] and
uh this dude's name was howie and he did
not [ __ ] around
he just did not [ __ ] he was baltimore
city like
just that resting [ __ ] face for a dude
too you know what i mean he's
always nicest [ __ ] guy though and
this dude's talking [ __ ] to this girl
over here and he's in her [ __ ] face
and howie just walks up
and i mean he doesn't even know these
we're just
and he just [ __ ] punches the dude
right in the goddamn throat
at that time he's just guys go and i
think he [ __ ]
crushed that dude's [ __ ] throat and
we're like what the [ __ ]
he's like don't [ __ ] ever talk to her
like that again you hear me and i was
like holy [ __ ]
that's scary that's a goddess [ __ ] while
we're
getting punched in the neck man adam's
apple surgery
yeah probably could you imagine that no
i don't even like why my teeth hurt i've
been in a ton of fights but i don't uh
not anymore
i will only fight now like if i have to
fight i will fight you know but i'm not
i i hear you i was that too like what
the [ __ ] you know right away
to yell and and be so angry but it
sounds like you had that when you're at
a
an age that made more sense i still have
it never goes away right that
you just have a better better grip on it
i love how you say i try because
i'd be lying if i didn't say the same
thing if i'm like no i pretty much got
it under control like
you could pay somebody to say something
when i leave today
where i'll punch him you know yeah i do
like there's a certain line where i'd be
like what up
okay well then go let's take a quick
break and tell you about our next
sponsor go henry now as a kid
i didn't really learn anything about
money all right i knew how to spend it i
knew how to save it for something
didn't really know anything about
budgets or tax or what anything cost had
a teacher in seventh grade
showed us how to write a check you don't
even do that anymore you don't even do
that anymore
okay teaching your own kids how to be
responsible with money doesn't have to
be tough go henry makes it easy to teach
kids a lifetime of financial skills
helping your kids be financially
literate can make a huge difference
in their future and go henry can help
all right
they sent me this i checked it out i
signed my daughter up for it
six years old you can put money on this
card all right you can put
you can make it for chores you can make
it for you know special occasions do
whatever you want okay
it is designed to help young people ages
6 to 18 learn about money firsthand
and build financial independence with
gohenry they can use their card to make
purchases
online in stores or at an atm and track
their spending in real time you can set
savings goals
you can help them make donations help
them learn to budget
and to practice generosity okay it's
easy for parents it's simpler than
handling cash and allows boundary
setting
and flexibility and you have real-time
money transfers
automated allowance deposits and tasks
that allow your kids
to earn extra money for completing
chores i know my daughter feels good
when we go to the store i tell her it's
20 bucks she's like oh this is
this is 20 i'm like ah pump the brakes
girl there's tax
she can go pay with her card now and
empowers these kids you can receive
real-time notifications about how much
your kid is spent
and where all right it's founded by
parents with the mission to make every
kid good with money it's got excellent
reviews on the app store google play
store
and trustpilot okay get started at
gohenry.com and get one free month with
promo code honeydew that's one free
month
at gohenry.com promo code honeydew
our next sponsor is truff now if you
guys like hot sauce like i like hot
sauce and i love me some hot sauce
you're gonna love
trough all right they sent me a whole
array of
i mean i got spicy truffle mayonnaise
regular mayonnaise uh with truffle all
black truffle i got pasta sauce arabiata
sauce i got
regular hot sauce spicy hot sauce i got
a white truffle hot sauce
all right this stuff is amazing it's so
good if you like truffles if you like
hot sauce
it's the perfect blend i can't say
enough good things about it man i've
tried everything they have
and i love all of it alright the brand
trough is a luxury hot sauce brand
inspired by the elegance and the
indulgence of truffles
exclusive eye popping and mouth-watering
it is a hot sauce brand
like none other okay truff's original
hot sauce blends black truffles ripe
chili savory spices
and organic agave nectar their hotter
sauce which is the one i really like
takes the heat up a notch with extra
jalapenos red chili and habanero for
those who demand the spicier things in
life
and the white trough hot sauce is
infused with rare and decadent white
truffle it's so good the packaging's so
great
i can't say enough good things about it
more than one billion organic shout outs
on instagram and over a million likes on
tick tock
it's the number one best-selling sauce
on amazon and it's the number one
best-selling sauce
on whole foods ten thousand plus
customer reviews
loyal chef fans around the world love it
and major streetwear co-signs featured
on oprah's favorite things twice
and there's no one i've given it to that
hasn't loved it the background
uh this thing all started back in 2017
there's two college friends
nick gian and nick agelooney they began
exploring the hot sauce industry
traditionally dominated by legacy brands
with no social media presence and little
connection to millennial and
gen z shoppers after two years spent
meticulously testing literally hundreds
of hot sauce recipes
out of their parents garage they landed
on trough a luxurious hot sauce infused
with black truffle
as a digital native brand trough carved
out a distinct space in an otherwise
ironically bland sea of hot sauces
all right get 15 this is all you got to
do and i'm telling you it's so good
get 15 off site wide plus free shipping
with promo code honeydew at truff.com
that's 15
all for everything at trough t-r-u-f-f
f as in fantastic dot-com
promo code honeydew now let's get back
to the do
i i'm look i'm big on principal um but
also yeah no i'm not perfect no i
[ __ ] yell
i snap not like i'll tell you what i
don't yell at my kid
you know my daughter she's like dad you
never yell and i'm like not to you
but you know i i certainly have my anger
issues but i believe like
i try working more and more because i
don't ever want to lose that edge either
i think
losing that edge all the way could be
detrimental to us
yeah because you know in a backward
[ __ ] up way
it is what has made us who we are it is
who i
this chip on my shoulder it's never
going to be filled in there's nothing
that's going to fill that chip in and i
don't want it to to be honest
i want to get i want to i want to make
those moments that i do that
less and less throughout my life like i
only did that [ __ ] three times this year
you know what i mean not this week this
month
um so i don't want that edge to go
because
as much as it's hurt me at times it's
also
helped me get all the way right here to
sit and talk to you and i feel like the
same thing
for you too like there's just this metal
that you've built that
that it shouldn't go away it's an armor
that i don't think you're ever going to
be able to take it off
yeah no i definitely don't think it ever
goes away for sure but that is an
interesting
and better way to look at it that it's
not always
[ __ ] my life over it's probably given
me a lot of drive we're alive because of
it right we're alive
like the whole serious thing like that
falling out
i didn't have time to [ __ ] about it i
was like we need to
we need to get it going i'm still like
well hey downloads everybody but
yeah and but i'm not man you don't mean
no one's having me on the
i'm like no i don't have time for that
like let's just go
get [ __ ] done i bel i say this a lot my
favorite one of my favorite sayings is i
come in peace
ready for war nice don't ever get rid of
that edge
but come here but if you want to go
we'll go
we'll go you know what i mean all right
you want to go we'll go
the casual will go that's the most
dangerous one it is yeah we'll go i know
it's really not that big of a deal
i'm not a talker i'm just going to come
in and throw that punch whether i hit
you or not cause i don't i know i i know
i'm out of shape
you see that's my better
i know everybody can say that every time
i do the ellis mania that's kind of like
when people that don't fight
that haven't had a fight in their life
it's not so much you could be fit you
could train for a fight but
if you've never had one and it's an
organized fight everybody holds their
breath and punches for the [ __ ]
for the it's over in 35 seconds they've
just gone
yeah and then they go and then the other
guy's like
it's just like what you watch two people
with so much fear
and so much little oxygen in their lungs
trying to understand which one they
should pick first
it's one of my fav my favorite thing is
the double
hand on your knees as soon as you see
that yeah it goes from the waist first
then down but when the other guy's so
tired when he sees that he
take partakes that's happened at alice
mania a few times where both guys are
just like you did it first sorry
mikey guys are awesome giving it their
all
i'm doing that again are you really yeah
this year we're going to try and do it
in vegas again
promote it uh well i don't have the date
all right well when you do come back and
promote supposed to be the virgin hotel
that was the hard right the hard rock
oh okay that's the virgin now yeah is
that like virgin airlines virgin yeah
yeah okay um all right so back to heroin
yeah so i guess i moved back to
australia because
kind of my tail between my legs i i mean
i my
australian wife we moved back to
australia i think i uh
still was getting paid by some companies
in america
uh back then you you kind of still had
to be in contests and i was
not doing that so i kind of figured i
was being retired
and i and i had to accept it because i
felt like going a contest was such a
nightmare with this guy that
it was no longer fun for me so i didn't
really i added it up pretty easy if it's
going to be
just a giant anxiety attack the whole
time
then i'm not gonna go so i go back to
australia
and then i don't have any time everybody
there has a job all my friends
so i'm just hanging out all day
so uh i get drunk whenever i get drunk
then i
uh try to get ecstasy or some [ __ ]
meth or some coke didn't matter uh but
then i figured out that there's a place
in synkilda
where all the prostitutes the the one
like the junky ones
so it's 50 bucks to get a blow job or
bang them or whatever
okay so i would drink enough to where
that switch would go on where i'm like
right now it's time to go there
and i would go there and then i noticed
that they were addicted to heroin
and i was like this heroin do you have
any
and one of them was like yeah and i was
like let me buy some mafia and
and she's like okay weirdo so
then i bought some so then my new
routine was
get drunk go to the prostitute thing get
some heroin and get a [ __ ]
and then would you [ __ ] them nah okay i
wanted to ask you if you if they would
make you wear
protection sometimes for a i've got a
[ __ ] from a hooker in the bushes in
cinquelta where i had a rubber on and i
could feel the heat
and i was like this rubber might not do
and it might i might need two
to deflect the amount of sexually
transmitted diseases that are in her
mouth oh my god it was
burning i'm like she got thrush in her
mouth it was that hot
[ __ ] streets are tough dude when you're
doing heroin
you got to suck off everybody i don't
think any i feel like i was probably one
of their better
clients had a nice dick and stuff at
least
i don't know so wait so then
so then i just i go to this this parking
lot
uh where i uh get the foil
and chase the dragon and this time not
like the first time
this time i figure out how to get real
high on it to the point where i start
vomiting
which is so gnarly you vomit and then
you say to yourself
that was one of the best times i've ever
had me sitting in a parking lot by
myself vomiting
and i'm like i can't wait to get back to
that feeling because i
hated my situation so much i've been
running from so many things
that there was no more room left i just
had to face
that i'm a runner you know like you
[ __ ] chickened out of this whole
thing
so then i really just didn't [ __ ]
care
and i remember just making the decision
next time i see
the prostitutes i'm going to ask them if
they should can shoot me up
so i went there and i got two girls
you know so i still was getting paid
from being a skateboarder so i still had
money
so you know and money didn't mean i
didn't understand it and i was just like
yeah [ __ ] here have the money
and yeah give me some heroin and shoot
me up and they're like really i'm like
yeah because i don't know how to do it
so hook me up
and uh so i'm having sex with one of
them and then they did have sex with her
yeah yeah you wear a condom for that i
can't remember god damn
i think they make i don't know where are
you having sorry where are you in
okay so they took me to this house that
was a lot it was the
all the curtains are rooms so the walls
are just curtains like massage parlors
yeah
so i don't even know i i'm so [ __ ]
high i don't even know how i got in
there or where i am
so i'm banging one of them and then the
other one like [ __ ] you know taps the
[ __ ] thing
you can [ __ ] on heroin well
let me finish the story
i'm i am [ __ ] her yeah and then that
goes in
and i'm gone i'm out so pass out like
i don't remember anything i woke up in a
park
freezing cold shaking so i'm unconscious
for a long period of time people had to
carry me somewhere
and dump me so they brought they robbed
me took me everything i had
and then they left me in this park where
i know it to be a park where
um you you can't be in there late at
night you you get killed like it's just
the sketchiest part
of melbourne the end so i wake up and i
don't even really years later i realized
that i probably
almost i might have od'd or i definitely
was in a lot of trouble and nobody was
gonna help me i was gonna die in that
park
but at the time i remember thinking okay
that
was not fun all the other heroin that i
was doing
pretty cool that one that was real bad
and i never did it again never had any
interest in it again
away from it there yeah all right so i
moved on from that and that was then and
it was still ecstasy and cocaine
all right there's something you said you
wanted to talk about you said
scarification
oh yeah so what is what is it man this
is an accident so i'm friends with
like my wife is friends with a bunch of
porn stuff i'm their friends too
but you know some of them got a crazy
life and one of them
my friend has a split tongue you know
she cut her tongue
so she's into crazy stuff so her best
friend
is a guy that does scarification one
time i went over to their house
it's when they cut um a picture
into your skin by using a scalpel
and like they they cut and peel your
skin off
wait what so i don't really know what's
happening
this is this so i do i'm do i got a
podcast the jason l show by myself
uh while i had the serious show and it
was more about me just being drunk and
talking to porn stars
so they go they go what about doing
scarification i go
yeah i'll do scarification and he's like
yeah we'll bring him over and he can do
it while you're doing the show
i'm like yeah okay sounds like a good
idea i don't
i didn't think about it i didn't even
know i'd already been to
her house to watch another girl have one
of her [ __ ] flaps cut off
first of all you call it a [ __ ] flat
it's not a [ __ ] flap
what is it a lip maybe a lip is it a
labia
it's not even a lemon is it a labia what
well she
she had a crooked back cut off a what a
crooked bat wing
they caught it you saw that dude she
said i said can i
get cl she was like yeah you have lived
the [ __ ] was right here and i was like
oh
cause he's like he gets he like holds it
and goes
yeah and straightened it out for her
like made it look nice yeah she cut it
he cut both sides to make him even
oh my god and then uh
so i was like yeah that guy's crazy he's
the guy that does like doctor stuff but
he's just like a tattooist
that's wild but he came over and then
they're like yeah we're gonna
we're gonna cut the thing and i'm like
and he gets the scalpel and comes
towards my leg and i'm like
whoa wait you ain't getting a number or
anything he's like oh it's
it's it doesn't work for the top of the
skin because
it's just the top of your flesh so like
it won't we find you won't even really
feel it
and i'm like okay so when he starts
cutting this
[ __ ] logo into my leg so he takes a
picture and lays it over just
he's the same way like we do attempt to
first okay he drew it with a marker
right and then he went through the
marker with a with a scalpel
got it just so a tattoo but instead of
the needle gun it's a scalpel he's
putting it yeah but it doesn't
tattoos do hurt more than a scalpel your
own flesh off yeah
i wouldn't think so no but it makes you
feel sick
what do you mean i didn't know that he
was gonna
run a scalpel down my i just didn't
occurred to me how this really works and
then
all of a sudden he's running this
scalpel down there and then when he gets
enough on he starts
he peels it and then starts cutting
under it
and i'm like oh
i'm like oh i don't know
i feel like i'm gonna pass out and he's
like really okay and i'm like i might
need a second here
but it didn't was there was no pain it
was just gross
it was like the grossest feeling ever i
found
that day that that's on my shin
the red dragon logo oh yeah it's
starting to like
go away but so how long ago did you get
it how long does it take to heal like
three years ago
and it start oh you mean it's starting
to go away yeah god gotcha gotcha
yeah but it's a very painful thing as in
just
your mind watching it i don't really
like getting my blood taken out
no i don't mind any of that stuff do you
watch it
yeah all the time i i what i'll tell you
what made me sick one time i had a um
like a cyst i had a cyst in my balls and
um i had to go for a couch okay now you
just leave it
you just leave wait do you have like a
third bowl no it's a
it's a tiny little thing you have a
small third bowl i got like a little
junior varsity
guy right a little little company
hanging on you know
i mean like uh what are those uh little
monkeys that go on the backs of
alligators and [ __ ]
right what are those that fish that like
lives off the back of a shark yeah
that's what i'm talking about right
um but i had to go get an ultrasound and
uh you know and
and they do this whole like they they
treat your dick very professionally you
know yeah
they towels and they fluff it up and put
[ __ ] up underneath
their fluffy dick they they put it they
set it on the towel
and then they pop up your balls and then
they squirt the solution off yeah yeah
yeah
the gel on yeah and then she's doing the
wand nice and it doesn't feel bad
it feels good yeah you know it feels
good i'm like yeah cause i like my balls
played with
i don't know anybody that doesn't like
their bulls being played i exceptionally
like it
oh really yeah and um tweak her i go hey
what are you uh what are you seeing over
there and she goes oh let me show you
and she turns the monitor
and i see the 3d imaging of my ball roll
i go is that my
testicle she goes yeah and immediately i
was like all of a sudden
seeing it seeing it roll made my stomach
just like
oh it was disgusting man i couldn't take
and then she was like
i want you to push down like you're uh
relieving your bowels
and when i would this little red area
would pop up where the cyst was she goes
there it is that's how i see it i'm like
oh
turn that [ __ ] screen i couldn't take
that [ __ ] man i got a
vasectomy and i went live on instagram
for it
so i'm talking or whatever and they're
they're cutting
cutting me open and the nurse goes the
nurse goes oh wow you've got unusually
thick balls and i'm like hell yeah this
is live on instagram
like [ __ ] mission accomplished i'm
[ __ ] studding out over here live on
instagram and then
and then all of a sudden because i've
got unusually thick balls
he's got a problem with trying to pull
this [ __ ] cord in my nuts
so he's all of a sudden he's like oh man
man this is really difficult
and then pulls on something and i feel
like a
crazy dude like a
horse kick to the testies all of a
sudden i'm like it's like oh and i'm
like
and i'm holding the phone am i like
holding the phone
yeah i was like oh [ __ ] because every
time i feel like i'm gonna faint i do
i fight it a couple of times
one time i dislocated my knee and uh and
and then i went on vacation and i had a
knee brace to go on vacation
because he broke it sideways so i had
like a proper motocross knee brace on
the whole time in mexico
and then i was getting a [ __ ] naked
with no knee brace on
and then room service came and i was
like oh and i was on the balcony and i
went to get up to get it
and my foot slipped and my knee went out
again
and she goes to get the the food because
she just sees me go down
grabbing the leg and i and i and i'm in
the just on the balcony going
stay conscious say god just say goddess
works almost every time well i never
fainted oh
[ __ ] i had a doctor my doctor he's still
my doctor doctor start what's up doctor
he uh who's tom segura's doctor oh
really he left i think tom's like more
powerful than me well he's moving
son of a [ __ ] man everybody left
my doctor told me one time he's giving
me these names like uh he goes you have
a
an unusually pronounced divider and i go
what are you talking about like the line
in between my balls
no the line like on your ball bag
there's a line that goes oh
god you up yeah yeah work never heard
that ever dude
god search you up
come on man praise check oh is that good
is that bad he goes i'm just saying it's
you know you gotta pronounce it yeah i
don't even know why he's saying i'm like
that's a weird that's what i tell them
you know i can actually see your line i
don't see the line a lot of times on
guys balls i'm like i don't give a [ __ ]
about other guys balls
weird in a medical [ __ ] thing yeah a
lot of back and forth on the ball he's
the best doctor though
okay one day i go in and i've had him
for like 20 years he doesn't
[ __ ] or anything and i i was do we
were doing a physical aren't you going
to check my balls he goes do you want me
to check your balls i'm like well now if
you don't need to check i mean like
i can tell you i don't have a hernia i'm
like oh okay then leave my body dude i
need a new daughter i got hemorrhoids
right now that are freaking me out it's
like [ __ ] hands coming out of my ass
i'm in hell over here dude yeah i've
been i'm sitting on one cheek this whole
show yeah we're gonna worry about we'll
wrap this
i'm [ __ ] cutting angles right now
just to survive
what's happening dude i got hemorrhoids
and then you know i mean i
keep doing stuff in my butt so i got to
stop doing butt stuff
yeah you got to stop doing but also when
they flare up you're not supposed to
work out and i just work out all the
time
so i got to the point where now i can't
work out for a couple of days cause
it's just stinging and you can't get it
can't see a butt doctor
for like two months are they backed up
yeah they're like go to urgent care i'm
not going to urgent care to show my dick
one time i went to urgent care to show
the lady my ass and she was like whoa
you got to see like like she didn't even
touch it she went whoa whoa
it's like it's hurting dude
one time did the the the same place same
lady one time i go there because
you know getting these stds and i'm like
i think i got [ __ ] chlamydia and
she's like oh yeah how do you know that
mike's because i've had it a couple of
times and she's like pull my pants down
and showed my dick
and she's like how do you because i'm
i've got a ronnie roll back i'm an uncut
and she's like how do you and i'm like
how do you get a
[ __ ] dick how do i get my head out
how do you get a human dick out
how do you get the knob out like how do
you pull the jacket down
same way everything [ __ ] comes like
how do you put socks on
[ __ ] face you know
you're a [ __ ] professional pull my
[ __ ] dick back
she made me do it oh i got one of these
come on back here we got one i got a
specialist comes in just sleeves it down
it's not how difficult of a concept is
it
to roll a dick back well i was hoping
she'd be like whoa you gotta go see a
specialist i don't know what about it
dude you're the best man thank you so
much for coming on let's give your
[ __ ] a rest here for real but before
we do
again promote everything please all of
it if
there's anybody out there that's a
professional wants to see my anus to
give me some help that would be cool
because
the streets don't want to see it so i do
need help thank you doctors because i
know doctors
they love they love you dude for sure my
doctor does
everything i was like one of my best
patients he probably does that for
everybody i don't want your doctor to
see my eyes because he might tell you
how bad he probably will tell me
yeah i don't know if i had to send him
to a specialist yeah everybody should
check out the jason alice show it's free
you can just check it out if you don't
like it okay [ __ ]
[ __ ] you what the [ __ ] i thought it was
pretty good myself but yeah check it out
and then
woof knife store as i said you can you
be helping my
me make that money from the money that i
got from my friend [ __ ] my ex-wife
think about that when you go there and
then hawk vs wolf that's a free podcast
and then of course i have a patreon just
like
ryan over here because i copy his stuff
so i ha
the jason show has a patreon forward
slash ellis mate
and i think that's it i think that's all
really just care about the json show
podcast i'm really trying to push it out
there
so that podcast people know that i'm
here too
you know just trying to hang out with
everybody and i don't i do want to also
mention your hulk versus wolf that's
drops yeah the okay yeah yeah the 24th
so that's that's a big deal too
hopefully that helps the jason
of course it will it'll all help
everything helps it'll all feed in
not as much as this dude that's
flattering i love hearing that
that's why i think i'm plugging the show
more this time because the last time you
like plug the show i'm like
yeah did jason i'll show check you were
just getting started too weren't you
probably had like three episodes yeah
you were just getting underway it's hard
as [ __ ] to get a
show off the ground too we figured out
apparently people don't want us to have
guests on i'm like hell yeah do you know
how hard it is to get people in there
especially in a pandemic
well even when it's not the hardest part
of podcasting is getting two or three
people
to sit down in a room for an hour on the
same goddamn day it's such a pain
how did everybody get so busy right like
i know you're all taking shits and
stuff like you got time thank you for
coming on any time
anytime you want you're welcome i know
we're not done with you uh as always
ryan sickler on all social media ryan
sickler.com
we'll talk to you all next week
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you